today on the mat wall show we are told
that racist cops are out hunting and
killing black people but is this
narrative actually true is there any
real evidence for it is there any reason
to believe it I think the truth really
matters so today we're gonna take a look
at the evidence and see where it points
also five headlines including a CNN
quote journalists going to rather
desperate rhetorical extremes to justify
rioting and looting and in our daily
cancellation I will cancel once and for
all the FBI may be a sort of inopportune
time to be canceling the FBI but they
don't seem to be doing much anyway so we
might as well cancel them and I'll
explain why all of that coming up but
before we get to any of that I want to
tell you about Duke canon you know it
Father's Day is is actually Father's Day
exist Father's Day is a thing okay
doesn't get as much attention as a
Mother's Day in fact my my daughter said
to me other day we were out and she said
she said daddy they they you know they
have the day for moms do they have a day
for daddies I said do they have a day
yes they have a day are you talking
about my own daughter didn't even know
that Father's Day exists okay so that
should tell you the kind of bias there
is but I'm now I'm way off track the
point is Duke canon is where you want to
go for Father's Day gifts to honor the
dads in our lives Duke Canon is offering
the Patriot collection filled with three
commander commemorative great American
beer soaps made with actual Budweiser
beer but it's more than beer soap made
in the USA that gives credence to its
name for every Patriot collection
purchased on Duke canon comm they're
gonna donate five dollars to folds of
Honor which is a nonprofit that provides
educational scholarships to spouses and
children of America's fallen and
disabled military service members so
you're getting to get great product
you're also contributing to a great
cause and I've used this beer soap
myself and it does it smells like you're
cracking open a beer and the shower it's
almost as good is actually drinking a
beer in the shower although don't drink
the soap I should warn you I made that
mistake
as a reminder Duke cannon partners with
active-duty military to develop new
ideas and review products anything that
doesn't meet the high standards of
soldiers doesn't happen so visit Duke
cannon comm use promo code walls for 10%
off your entire order free shipping with
orders over $20 a range of Duke cannon
men's premium products are also
available at your local target Duke
canon comm go there now ok now let's
talk about this there is there is an
epidemic of police brutality in this
country and much of the brutality is
motivated by racism right black
Americans are quite literally being
hunted by racist whites many of whom
wear a badge and carry a gun
hunt it is the exact word that is used
even by prominent voices like LeBron
James it isn't safe it's not even safe
for black people especially men to leave
their homes because of the problem of
homicidal racist cops that problem is so
pervasive that it's not even safe for
them this anyway is the narrative that
is relentlessly hammered into our heads
by the media Hollywood activists the
Democrat Party but of course I repeat
myself considering that this narrative
is currently fueling violent mobs all
across the country and those violent
mobs are torching our cities and
unraveling the fabric of civilized
society I think it really matters
whether it's actually true or not and a
close inspection of the relevant
statistics which we're going to get into
now along with a generous helping of
common sense that I think we should
apply to the situation as well would
seem to cast very serious doubt on this
claim it is the claim again that is
sending people into the streets all over
the country I'm not sure there's
anything to it now the first thing that
we should note is that police kill twice
as many white men as they do well white
people it's mostly men and we'll get to
that in a second
but police killed twice as many white
people as they do black people in a
given year now the white victims don't
receive anything like the same kind of
attention but they exist and they are
more numerous than the black victims in
fact the most egregious police shooting
I think by far in recent history is the
one that claimed the life of a guy named
Daniel shaver Daniel shaver is a white
man he was unarmed and he was gunned
down while on his knees begging for his
life in
in the hallway of a hotel it's all on
video me this is this is what they
claimed happen to Michael Brown but
didn't happen in that case where he was
on his knees saying hands up don't shoot
ok that was a lie
that was invented by the media actually
was a lie invented by you know I think
originally by Michael Browns criminal
friend and then amplified by the meet it
didn't happen it was a lie here it
actually did happen almost exactly that
happened the officer who killed Daniel
shaver was not convicted of any crime in
fact you know I wasn't sure if I was
gonna do this but I think I will I want
to play some of this video for you of
the Daniel shaver killing if you haven't
seen it now I warn you it's extremely
upsetting
it's not graphic now this the video I'm
gonna play is from the Washington Post
the actual shooting itself is blurred
out so you're not gonna see anything I
can see any blood or into graphic but it
but it is very upsetting I think it's
necessary to play the video so that you
could actually see it and and and when
you watch it keep in mind that these are
two white people involved is a white
officer and a white man no racial
element and yet this happened you are to
keep your legs across do you understand
me you are to put both of your hands
palm down straight out in front of you
push yourself up to a kneeling position
hands straight up in the air do not put
your hands down for any reason you think
you're gonna fall you're gonna fall on
your face your hands go back into small
your back are done we are going to shoot
you do you understand me crawl towards
me shaver was unarmed he was trying to
comply he was weeping and begging for
his life
they threatened repeatedly to kill him
so tensions are high you know he's
trying to comply but he's scared who
wouldn't be
who wouldn't be you've got you guys
think it was three the three cops
responded to that scene they got guns
drawn on you you're on your knees they
keep threatening to shoot you and the
instructions they're giving are
confusing and contradictory at one point
you know is put the he's down on it on
the ground hands hands out legs crossed
then they say get up and start crawling
and then they yell at him for not
keeping his legs crossed well how the
hell are you gonna crawl with your legs
crossed I don't even understand that and
nobody's got a gun pointed at me it's
like a game of Simon Says except if you
lose you die and he lost
now finally the reason the reason they
shot him is that he was crawling and
then his pants started to fall down he
made the mistake of trying to pulls
pants up why did he try it pulls pants
up well it's just a reflex and maybe he
didn't want to crawl pantless on the
ground like a dog and and and because he
tried to preserve a little bit of his
dignity they shot him dead now this is
horrible the officer should have gone to
jail in my opinion he didn't yet the
point here is that there is no racial
element and also not coincidentally no
riots over that none at all
speaking of horrifying video there's
also footage of the last moments of a
man named Tony tempos
life tempeh white man was suffocated
during an arrest much like the George
Floyd situation he screamed and pleaded
for his life 30 times before he died he
said he was dying he was gonna die
officers on the scene laughed and
cracked jokes as he lay there dead on
the pavement now I'm not gonna play this
video because there's only so many so
much of this kind of content you could
watch in one sitting but you can find
the video for yourself what's online
tempeh also by the way the reason cops
showed up is that tempeh called them to
come help him use them he suffered for
mental illness and he called them to
come help him they end up killing him in
the process now tempest case like
shavers like so many others never
attracted the coverage or the outrage on
anywhere near on par with the killings
of George Floyd or Michael Brown or
Freddie gray or any of the other black
victims who have become household names
you know some of these these people have
been killed by cops are household names
now are any of them white no but again
these white victims exist in they
outnumber their black counterparts by a
wide margin in fact now listen this is
not about what about ISM this is not
about racial scorekeeping or anything
like that this is about addressing a
narrative that is currently as I said
fueling the destruction of our cities we
have to address this narrative because
if it's not true that matters doesn't it
it really really matters and I'm saying
it's not true it's just not true it will
be pointed out of course that there are
many more white people than black people
in the country so the fact that the fact
that more white people are killed by
cops is you know is not a surprise and
does not in itself disprove the racist
police narrative and that's true of
course but consider a couple of things
and before we even get there I mean it
is true but even so even though there
are a lot more white people if this is a
problem of racist police out hunting
black people even though there are fewer
black people you still wouldn't expect
based on that fear
right of the racist police hunting black
people you-you-you still wouldn't expect
for there to actually be more white
victims but there are so so so that is a
conclusion or a fact that is not
predicted by the theory of racist cops
hunting black people also you know a a
person arguing in favor of the racist
police narrative must have an
explanation for the shavers and the
tempers and the hundreds of other white
victims you have to
you've got your theory again your theory
is racist police out hunting black
people okay that's your theory
how ok but now you've got all this
information over here that doesn't
really comport with your theory how do
you explain it you got to have some
explanation if all or most of the black
victims were shot because of racism
which appears to be the theory because
every single - every single time there
is video of a of a black person dying in
the process of an arrest or being killed
by police
whether justly or unjustly or if there's
a story about it Michael Brown there was
never any video it turns out the killing
was not unjust but it did happen in any
case anytime the automatic assumption is
that it's racism which which which would
seem to indicate that all or most of the
black people killed by cops are killed
because of racism ok well then again why
were the white victims shot in that case
however you explain the white victims
how do you know that the same
explanation or combination of
explanations doesn't also apply to the
black victims I mean why do we assume
racism for the black victims well while
assuming any number of other
explanations for the white victims if
there are a slew of potential reasons
why a white guy might get shot by the
cops including that he was the aggressor
and brought it on himself
of course because it's not like it's not
it's not like every police shooting is
unjust so I'm using this word victim you
know I'm just using it for brevity's
sake but of course not every
back who's killed by police is a victim
many times this is the aggressor I mean
there are many when you look at the
statistics of people shot by the cops
keep in mind that a lot of them were
shooting at the cops and that's why they
got killed that's not the case for
George Floyd of course just like it
wasn't Kate the case for Daniel shaver
or or Tony tempo but it does happen
either way you know when we talk about
the white victims there are a whole slew
of explanations how can we rule out all
of those explanations from the start
whenever a black person is killed by the
cops how does that make any sense to do
now
Tony Tempah why did he die maybe because
the officers involved weren't bigots but
they were reckless bullies who didn't
place a high enough value in human life
okay that's terrible but it's not
bigotry it's not racism if that's how we
explain Tony tempo or Daniel shaver you
know I see that it's clearly not racism
because those are white people all all
white people involved but what I see is
a power trip I see a police officer who
was on a power trip and just loves the
fact that he's got the gun and he's got
the power that's how I explained it how
can we disqualify that explanation from
the outset where George Floyd is
concerned you can't say well George
Floyd is he he was killed because of
racism that exact thing also happened to
a white guy so so what however you
explained it for the white guy how do
you know that doesn't also explain this
do you have additional evidence that
this police officer was racist if you do
present it if cops kill white people too
how is the mere fact that a black man
was killed by cops evidence in itself
for racism also and this part is
politically incorrect okay this is where
the whole thing is politically incorrect
but now we're gonna get the really
politically incorrect part but it's a
point that cannot be avoided so I'm not
going to avoid it there are enough
people out there who are avoiding hard
truth
I'm not going to do it here's a hard
truth crime statistics show that a
disproportionate amount of violent crime
in this country is committed by black
people okay that's just the statistic
what does it mean well this means that
there will be a disproportionate amount
of potentially hostile interactions
between police and black people that's
what it means so the real question then
is this is the question it's it's
whether a black person is significantly
more likely to be unjustly killed in an
interaction with police than a white
person the answer to that question would
appear to be no in fact it was recently
put I think in a you know pretty
persuasive way by somebody on Twitter
who compiled the statistics Leonidas
Johnson I'll show you this a black man
by the way not that it matters but this
is this clearly is not someone who's you
know trying to excuse racism and he
frames it this way and he provides the
links with all the sources and these are
this is the information anyone can go
find for yourself the information is out
there so three black people are killed
for every 10,000 arrested for violent
crime among among white people arrested
for violent crime the figure is four in
10,000 so when you frame it this way
it's really hard to support the claim of
a racist Police epidemic once again
the racist police narrative is a theory
it's an explanatory theory it's it's
meant to explain why we see police
brutality
well theories are supposed to have
predictive power they're supposed to
predict the facts that we see the racist
police narrative does not predict that
three and ten thousand black people
arrested for filing for violent crime
will be killed while four in 10,000
white people are killed doesn't predict
that doesn't explain it doesn't comport
with it it also seems relevant that
white cops they've done Studies on this
white cops are not more likely to shoot
black suspects and that stat would
comports with the fact that many of the
high-profile police killings Baltimore
for example I think about Freddie gray
that
happened in a black run city with a
black mayor of black police chief and
many black officers were involved in the
killing yet they still called it racism
I mean if racism lies at the root of
police brutality and if black men are
indeed being hunted then we should
observe a lot more brutality and quote
hunting in departments and cities where
there are more white cops and more white
leadership but that is not what we
observe if the theory was true that is
what we would observe but it's not what
we observe so there's a problem with the
theory also as I as I referenced earlier
keep in mind that men are much more
likely to die by police shooting than
women much more likely ok now this makes
little sense on the bigotry theory I
mean are the police feminists as well as
are they radical feminists as well as
racists how do you explain that
or are men more likely to be killed by
police because they're more likely to
commit violent crime which in turn
increases the likelihood of an explosive
interaction with cops
now if the latter is the case when it
comes to the men versus women disparity
and we all probably agree that it is
then why can't the same explanation be
applied to the racial disparities as to
the sex disparities why not if the
problem of police brutality affects
white people and black people and if it
persists even under black leadership and
even at the hands of black cops then it
would seem that we need to search for an
answer other than racist cops or hunting
black folks that's it what it would
really seem like now I believe there is
a problem with policing in this country
you know what happened to George Floyd
and Tony Tempah and Daniel shaver that
was unacceptable outrageous happens far
too often but I'm not gonna pretend that
I think the racial narrative is true
because it's not true the problem is not
racist cops there is no evidence for
that and there's a lot of evidence to
the contrary and the truth
matters the truth matters it matters now
more than ever this is not like
splitting hairs or or being pedantic
this is the truth and it's very
important the truth is that the racial
narrative offered as an explanation for
this problem ignores the facts on the
ground is incoherent fails as a theory
and is promoted by race hustlers
operating in bad faith and for their own
ideological and political ends that's
the truth and from there we will move on
to headlines number one as looting and
rioting gripped hold of the country for
what was a seventh I think it's a
seventh seventh day in a row eighth or
seventh or eighth president Trump
finally addressed the nation yesterday
and said that we should you know
mobilize the military and then he took a
walk down the street and and visited the
church that had been set on fire the
night before
now the left was very upset about this
obviously has to be expected very
offended by the photo-op they also
claimed this is what we this is the
claim that we got was all over the
internet in the media last night the
claim was that cops cleared out a bunch
of peaceful protesters with tear gas
canisters in order for Trump to walk
through into his photo op well I've come
to find out today
the the police department was was asked
about this and they said that no we
didn't use tear gas we use smoke
canisters there's no irritant and it's
not gonna hurt anybody and we did it
because they were throwing stuff at us
and oh by the way we didn't even know
Trump was coming we didn't do it for
Trump so you know that story was true
except for the fact that everything
about it was untrue now you know
personally the photo-op and everything
I'm not offended by that I think it was
I think it's a good move I like the
speech I think it's all pretty good the
only problem is that it's about six days
too late and I understand that in recent
years the tradition is to give rioters
and looters about a week you know a free
week to do whatever the hell they want
and destroy whatever they want that's
that's what we've been doing ever since
Ferguson but that is not a tradition
that we should carry on with
you know and and that's not a tradition
that Trump Trump should observe in my
opinion as for bringing in the military
yes do it I mean do it yesterday do it
last week anarchists and domestic
terrorists are destroying communities
all over the country and these are not
fringe elements this is despite what we
are told this is all over the country
yes bring in the military you know we
use the military to restore order and
address these kinds of issues in foreign
cities to protect foreign citizens of
those cities you know in places like
Afghanistan and Syria and Iraq well why
not this country isn't that a novel
concept use the military to protect
American citizens not not not at
citizens of Afghanistan or Iraq American
citizens I mean people are so shocked by
the idea of sending in the military
because we've gotten so used to this
this this concept of using our military
to protect other people in other
countries using our military to protect
other people of other countries we've
gotten so used to that that we think
that that's what the military is for
that's not what the military is for the
military is to protect us it's our
military it's not Afghanistan's military
it's not Iraq mill it's our military
number to a video went viral yesterday
first shared by a reporter from the
Gothamist Jake open hearts was his name
and I'll show you the video in a second
here's the caption he offered on Twitter
says a source shared this video which he
says he took at around 10 p.m. near 12th
and Broadway it appears to show an NYPD
officer pointing a gun at protesters
outside the Strand sounds pretty scary
ok you've got a according to him officer
just pull his gun out peaceful
protesters what's going on let's take a
look at the video
geez why was that guy that officer
pointing a gun at peaceful protesters I
come I did that that's that I mean this
this is with it you this just proves it
this proves that we've got all these
crazy homicidal cops out there well no
actually it doesn't because you know our
friend Jake here he he accidentally cut
off the first part of the video okay
totally by accident I'm sure totally by
accident not because he's a piece of
garbage now it couldn't be that it's a
coincidence that he forgot to include
the part where a peaceful protester
sneaks up behind a police officer and
beats him over the head with a brick but
I have that part and I'll show it to you
here's the full video with with the part
that our friend Jake forgot to include
here it is
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
oh okay
well okay so the they were being
attacked with bricks which can kill
somebody and then that's why they pulled
a gun out all right well the clip that
that cuts that part out to the context
the clip that Jake open-heart shared has
millions of views and he had to take the
time and the effort to go in and trim
this thing down to only include the
reaction from the officer and not the
thing that he was reacting to this
obviously is deliberate and think about
how evil it is okay we've already got
chaos in the streets people are already
being attacked police are being attacked
and run over four police officers were
shot in st. Louis last night so Jake
here goes and deliberately tries to
stoke more aggression more hostility
towards the police by lying and by
distorting he's trying to get cops
killed this is pure evil this is a bad
person engaging in pure evil for his own
selfish reasons number three and now a
word from the illustrious publication
team vote one of my favorites you know
I've got a subscription I was reading I
was routine vote when they come in and
they shared one of their articles today
titled here's what an tyfa is really
trying to do and the article says of the
excerpt of the article says and Tifa
grows out of a larger revolutionary
politics that aspires towards creating a
better world but the primary motivation
is to stop racists from organizing
creating a better world yes well I guess
it depends on how you define better if a
bunch of burned-out stores and anarchy
in the streets and innocent people being
beaten unconscious is an improvement in
your mind then yes auntie feh has
certainly made the world a better place
but then in that case you're a
psychopath well I guess I should stop
myself no because you know the people at
Teen Vogue or elsewhere in the media who
make excuses for and lend rhetorical
support to or even practical support to
domestic terrorists are not psychotic
actually they are not mentally ill they
are not stupid either despite
appearances they know what they're doing
and that's what makes this so evil for
example another example moving on to
number four
I want you to watch this this I don't
know what you call a news report is that
what this is pretending to be I don't
know but watch this from CNN a couple
nights ago and here is Don Lemon
sorry don't think it's Don Lemon one of
them over there talking to a
quote-unquote reporter on the ground
watch I know people see violence and
think that people are just taking
advantage of the situation and there may
be some people who are I don't know that
every single person is doing this born
out of pain but I can tell you many
people are we've seen it they don't know
what to do with that emotion so their
response especially young folks is to
lash out and one of the young folks we
talked to him on your show you had him
on your show a young man who is from
Minneapolis who said do you see all this
damage here you don't listen to us when
we speak so you listen to us now don't
you so acting out gets attention and
they know that because the other way
hasn't gotten them the attention it
hasn't done anything it hasn't changed
anything
so they're hoping this will will it I
don't know I was in Ferguson in 2014 for
three months we're back here again same
scenario just about there wasn't a gun
involved there was a knee involved born
from pain pain yes these people are in
such pain such a pain they're suffering
from actually let me play another report
for you this is from CBS and here we can
see just you know she's talking about
the pain these people are in well here
is some of these in pain people lashing
out in their despair and anguish and
let's so let's take a look at what that
looks like
I'm Jonathan Vigliotti in Southern
California the site of some of the worst
looting in America we saw it firsthand
in Santa Monica this is a sushi store
here you can see the chairs were thrown
around even the computers ripped off
and here we have a jewelry store so
across the street we've got the
Patagonia what you're seeing is people
of all ages all backgrounds such pain
look at the pain on these people's faces
as they steal surfboards they are there
they're there weeping weeping for the
life of George Floyd as they run into
the destroyed stores and run off with
arms full of product right we just get
actually could we get a still a still
shot a screen shot at six seconds on
that video so there you go
I just want to focus on this guy for a
second he's got a bunch of boxes there
what about what are the shoes shoe boxes
I don't know what that is
who knows let's assume there's stuff
inside those boxes the point is don't
you see the pain this man is in the pain
the grief the agony they you could see
it right
inside it's written all over him no you
don't actually because he's not in pain
he's inflicting pain he is stealing he's
a thief he's a criminal he's a low-life
he's a scumbag everyone running out of
that store all the rest of them who are
looting stores across the country and
the thing is even if they were in pain I
don't care that's what I said yesterday
I'll say it again I'll say it every day
all this is going on I don't care if
you're in pain and you're looting a
store I don't care about your pain I
don't care I don't care what you've been
through doesn't matter it is immaterial
no sympathy I don't want to hear your
story you know your
are irrelevant in fact I hope you're in
pain I hope you're in pain from the
guilt and the shame that you should feel
pain from the realization of what an
absolute scumbag you are I hope you feel
that pain for your own sake so that you
can improve and actually become a decent
human being and not live your whole life
like this not live your life as the kind
of person who would see you know a store
that's been destroyed anything let me
run in and get get my share of that now
that's a miserable way to live and if
you're actually looking I mean you know
IIIi just can't imagine doing that and
getting home and catching a glimpse in
the mirror and thinking this is who I am
this is the kind of person I am I am
just a scumbag I'm a low-life horrible
person that I would do that so I can't
imagine having to confront that if you
actually confront it yeah there's gonna
be a lot of pain you're gonna feel a lot
of pain and I hope you feel that pain
for your own sake because that's the
only way you're ever going to improve
but I suspect that you don't feel it
because you're a bad person
and bad people don't feel pain or guilt
or shame for the bad things they do now
CNN is robit running cover for these
people coming up with elaborate excuses
you know and by the way she says they're
lashing out they want to be heard and
the you know the one the one
quote-unquote protesters as well you
hear us now you're paying attention no
we don't hear you now actually we're not
paying attention whatever it's supposed
message you have we're actually not
paying attention to it we care about it
less now than we did before your chance
to be heard was before you set the place
on fire if you didn't do that then I'd
listen to it once you do that I don't
hear anything
I don't hear anything you say I don't
care about anything you say but I do
wonder though that reporter or whatever
we call her who was talking about the
pain you know what if somebody burned
her house to the ground
stole all her stuff would she excuse it
would she tolerate it would she done
will she understand it because the
arsonist is in pain what do you think
you know somebody show
at her house with a torch in the middle
of the night what do you think she
thought I was look at that person in
pain you learnt so much pain yeah go
ahead and just burn it burn it burn it
down I I get it I get it you're trying
to send them in the stand you see it's
really easy for people at CNN and
elsewhere in the media to be
understanding and tolerant about the
destruction of other people's property
very easy takes nothing no sacrifice all
it takes is a narcissistic lack of
concern a lack of empathy for real
victims and if you have that if you have
that level of narcissism yeah you can
tolerate and understand crime all day
long but the moment it comes for you
everything changes doesn't it you know
that quote-unquote reporter someone
comes to her house to burn it down she's
not gonna be understanding she's not
gonna care about their pain and what is
she gonna do she's gonna call the cops
she's gonna call the racist cops to come
help her isn't she finally here's a
video that I'm told is inspirational and
heartwarming I don't know maybe I'm just
cynical but you take a look and tell me
I'm interested in your take on this go
ahead
okay now in fairness after that part the
black people in the crowd did join the
white people in kneeling and praying
okay so I don't want to be guilty of
cutting stuff up that does happen next
and and and that part's great you know
kneeling together and praying I'm all
about that great stuff but kneeling
before a group of people actually
kneeling but kneeling to them which is
which is what appears to be happening
here and begging for their forgiveness
that is to me is not inspirational and
it's not heartwarming that is groveling
it's pitiful it is idol worship if you
want to kneel together again
fantastic I'm all for it but one race
literally kneeling to the other that is
not equality it's not gonna fix anything
groveling and self-flagellation and
self-loathing that is not gonna fix
anything I can tell you that it's only
gonna make it worse now we're gonna move
on to our daily cancelation and it's a
good one but before we get there
speaking of good stuff how about this
they leftist tears tumblr this is what
can solve all of our problems in society
I think if everyone had one of these you
wouldn´t have all this strife and
everything in the world because they
would say to themselves at least I can
keep my beverage hot or cold
now you think about what one left is
tears tumblr does what about to the
devil tumblr
deal is back okay but it's only
available for our most exclusive
membership tier all access the all
access membership tier is our premier
level of membership all access members
get to participate in all access live
which is our brand-new interactive
programming feature where one of the
daily wire hosts hangs out at nights and
we you know have a just have a casual
conversation I'll be the the guy on the
docket today 8:00 p.m. Eastern 5:00 p.m.
Pacific all-access membership now
includes two of the irreplaceable
leftist ears tumblers and the tumblers
are just overflowing with with with
tears of the thought of this offer but
in this case tears of joy that a crumb
this in fact right now is filled with
tears of joy as we speak finally all
access members also get the benefits of
our other members four tiers including
an ad-free website experienced access to
our all live to our live broadcasts and
show library and three hours of ben
shapiro show along with dedicated
editorials from yours truly that means
me by the way so head over to daily wire
comm slash subscribe to join all access
and get 15% off with the coupon code
walsh right now that's daily wire.com
slash subscribe see you there okay now
today for our daily cancellation we are
canceling the FB i-- and the reason
there are many the FB i--'s given us
many reasons over the years especially
recently to cancel it but right now the
reason is this this tweet that was sent
out yesterday from the FBI's official
twitter account it says at the FBI we
know that diversity makes us stronger
during hashtag pride month
the FBI celebrates the contributions of
our LGBT colleagues as who have made the
contributions that our LGBTQ colleagues
have made to our country and our mission
ok so just to review domestic terrorists
are invading our cities burning
buildings attacking police officers
throwing the country into the grip of
Anarchy chaos violence trying to
fundamentally destroy this assess our
society and the FBI is instead focused
on gay pride month and the wonders of
diversity that's what they're telling us
about right now that's that's what
they're focused on just to be clear but
you know I do kind of actually
appreciate as much as I'm as much as I'm
cancelling the FBI for this I also
appreciate
Gay Pride Month is happening right now
in the middle of widespread riots and
also in the middle of a pandemic and
everything else at a moment in history
that is truly unprecedented in many ways
because I'll tell you why I appreciate
it because it just it throws into sharp
relief the the pity the silliness of the
whole thing of Gay Pride Month the
concept because who's concerned about
this right now
right who gives a damn about celebrating
Gay Pride at a time like this we're
struggling to hang on to our
civilization and our LGBT activists off
on the sidelines saying hey guys not to
interrupt but did I tell you I'm gay did
I mention that just just want it okay
get back I just want to let just one to
let you know get back to trying to save
civilization but just you know just so
you know my sexual orientation I don't
if you wanted to applaud me go ahead I'm
not gonna insist actually I do insist by
the way the tweet says we know that
diversity makes us stronger really how
so how does it make us stronger I mean
in what way has the FBI gotten better
stronger through diversity I'm not
saying it hasn't I'm just asking I'm
asking you in what way has can you
provide some sort of that's the theme of
this show evidence you have evidence for
this this is another popular claim I'm
just wondering if there's any evidence
for it whatsoever is there any reason to
believe that this is true that diversity
makes us stronger especially sexual
orientation diversity could anybody at
the FBI explain that one I would just
like to know what the explanation is
that that's all I'm asking for the
evidence give me specific quantifiable
ways in which the FBI is better at
performing its job because of the
diversity of sexual orientations within
its ranks I'd like to hear that that's
all
and again oh you know maybe it's but but
I'd like for someone anyone anyone who
goes around prattling on about diversity
is our strength I'd like for any of them
to actually offer some kind of evidence
to support that assertion
when you say diversity is our strength
the diversity makes us better diverse
makes us stronger okay how so that's my
follow-up question how so now if what
you mean to say is that you think it's
most ethical and most moral and most
right you know to focus on diversity or
something like that then say that yeah
that's a very different claim but if you
claim that your focus on diversity
actually makes us as a people or you as
an organization verifiably quantifiably
better and stronger then you need to
show some receipts okay of course even
if they did just mean that focusing on
diversity is ethical I would still
disagree and in here's what I'm gonna
say and this is also heretical another
theme of the show you know heresies of
the of the common narratives political
incorrectness that's a theme of every
show so I know this is an awful thing to
say we're not supposed to say it but but
I will diversity in itself doesn't
matter diversity in itself is
meaningless you know getting a whole
bunch of people of different races
nations and creeds together and
orientations that in itself is not
automatically praiseworthy that doesn't
automatically mean anything what really
matters is that you are getting everyone
together you know it's what you're
getting everyone together to do so you
can throw a bunch of people in a room
and they all look different have
different orientations everything's
different lot of diversity great okay
now what what what is it that we're
doing and if it's the FBI then I guess
where we're getting them together to
investigate federal crimes are we better
now at investigating federal crimes no
if if the goal is to investigate federal
crimes then your focus should be on
finding the people who are the best at
performing that specific task that is
the Federal Bureau of Investigation now
their race and Creed and orientation is
immaterial if all the best people happen
to be white so be it
that's the way the cookie crumbles if
they all happen to be black so be it if
they all happen be Native American
Korean if they all happen to be
polyamorous Australian transsexuals
whatever it is what matters in this
context is the task at hand and who is
best suited to perform it though I do
admit of course an FBI comprised solely
of polyamorous Australian transsexuals
does sound pretty interesting you know
maybe it would make for an interesting
sitcom or something I don't know if I
don't know if there'd be enough to
actually fill an entire FBI in any case
that's what it's about you know it's
it's if you're saying we need diversity
I think I think it's fair to follow up
with a question of for what we need
diversity okay for what what are we
doing tell me what we're doing and then
we'll figure this thing out
and I think most of the time what you're
gonna find is that what we really need
whatever the context what we really need
are just people who are good at doing
that thing whatever it happens to be and
many times what you're gonna find is
that if you focus on merit and you focus
on who's who's best actually doing the
thing that we're trying to do you're
gonna end up with some amount of
diversity that that is usually the way
that cookie that particular cookie
cookie happens to crumble it's just it
might not be exactly you know in line
with different quotas and everything
else it might not work that way but
you'll you'll end up with some of that
and that's great because then you know
what you have then you have something
like an actual meaningful diversity
because you got a bunch of people
together you're focused on merits you
got the best of the best doing it and
they happen to be you know have
different backgrounds everything else so
they're bringing different perspectives
to it great good stuff but
focused more on the background in the
demand and the demographics and that's
what your your if you're starting with
that then you're just gonna have you're
gonna be an effective ineffective I'm in
effect I can't even say I can't even
speak I'm ineffective podcast so I can't
speak so that's my that's my point about
that and I think we will have to wrap it
up there and we continue to pray for
this country I think that's what we all
need to be doing more of I need to be
doing more of it we all need to be doing
it because these are precarious times
indeed
so stay safe out there god bless
Godspeed
the Matt Walsh show is produced by Sean
Hampton executive producer Jeremy boring
our supervising producers are Mathis
Glover and Robert Sterling our technical
producer is Austin Stevens edited by
Dani D'Amico and our audio is mixed by
Robyn Fenderson the Matt Walsh show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 20 if you prefer facts over
feelings aren't offended by the brutal
truth and you can still laugh at the
insanity filling our national news cycle
well tune in to the Ben Shapiro show we
will get a whole lot of that and much
more see you there